Fuck yeah, do you feel it?
Ah?
AAAAAAAAAAA
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Yes, I love yes, oh
Good fucking God shut up. Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to another game about love. Now, you know me
I'm a creature of love. Inside my heart burns yearning love for the power of a thousand suns.
I love love, and I love to love love
And I love when I get love
And when you get love you know that you love love lover than love.
So together we're gonna go on an amazing dating experience, with your
wAiFu
Which everyone knows is Japanese for love of your life, and so when we go on this experience together,
you know that these, these bad hands right here. They're gonna find love. They're gonna feel love!
ohHHH
Now.
With this game, I need you to pay attention very closely because this is a story of love
And I'm gonna be exploring it for you, but don't be afraid to put yourself in my body while we play this together
There's more than enough ~waifu~ to go around for everybody. It doesn't just have to be about me oh no
It can be about us all. So please, close your eyes, open your hearts,
yearn deep in your loins for the luscious feeling of love.
Alright let's do this.
"Mei." Not like Overwatch Mei, but Mei "in the uncanny valley" Mei.
Hi!
Hello!!!
Mei, it's me!
MEI
MMMMEEEE----
"These TV programs are so boring," you say
Oh, I would like to play something. Why are you looking over there? Look-- oheeeyyy!
Uhhhh....
Okay! Ohhh....
Mae
Listen I would love-- ay, whoa, HEY WHOA WHOA WHOA HEY
"Come play with me." Okay well...oh...
"Beat Mei three times to unlock the next stage."
Alright, oooh.
Mei, I love you. Are you not gonna go first? You're gonna let me go first??
*gasp* oh my goodness
I can't believe it. Go first I will. Imma beat you though.
Nevermind
You're bound-- well, I mean, you don't have to be so rude about it. Jeez. Alright, here we go.
Nope
Um, *whap*
Uh.. okay, alright then! Gonna pretend that didn't happen.
ALRIGHT
Not every time, you mean not any time. I haven't actually made a target yet.
OKAY
Now its...
Okay well can I have a do-over? I really didn't do good this time Mei.
Alright. Mei, you show me what you can do, Mei.
If you're so special.
Mei? Oh--
Wow...
Why is this happening to me?! All right Mei you got this Eye of the Tiger! sorry I'm drooling
wow...
Okay
To be so happy about it also where the fuck do we live
What kind of penthouse amazing apartment do you have okay?
Huh Oh?
Mei can you not gloat I have a severe disability in that I have no arms
I have to control these puppets with my mind. Alright Mei
Wow, Mei you suck?
Damn?? Watch your mouth Mei! Mei. Can I- Can I talk -- whoa okay, Mei
Sorry I want-  do you want to appeal? I don't even - wait, what? I-I dont... Mei, listen to me
You little shit if you think I'm gonna stand for this Mei. It ain't gonna happen. I know it's em-- woah
I know it's empty in that head of yours
Huh oh you're good at darts. Oh, you're good at darts. Huh well it's not
Cause we're gonna play again, and I'm going to show you
All right give you one more chance. Oh, I don't even need one more chance
I need this many more chances okay beat me three times to unlock the next I gotta beat this
I can't even beat it once. Let's lean forward is this cheating is this cheating
damn
Why are you so lucky you know, I don't know Mei, I I just don't know Mei oh
My god Mei. I'm pretty good
I'm real good, Mei. Mei, I'm pretty good Mei. What do you think of that?
Well alright fuck you oh
Now it's your turn to suck get ready to be glad. Good shit talk mark great job. Okay, yeah
Why is this happening it's because you're terrible Mei
Mei, you're the worst you're the worst
I've ever seen and you're short too - and I'm tall obviously look how tall I am compared to you
Okay
that's a bit excessive separation so
That's a bit excessive celebration for something as mediocre as the two is what I was gonna say
But then it came out is bullshit out of my mouth, so it kind of lost the punch of the ability to insult you
Is that a 3?
I'm very clearly not oh
Oh, I'll be dammed oh
I'll be damned! I'll be damned if I'm gonna lose to you
Wow... Mei...
Uh, Mei you are literally the worst, but I'll beat you again cool
Come on come on what okay one of three not so bad. Okay? I just got to win three- two more times
Through my ultimate incredible method of totally not cheating
I got I got one Mei...it wasn't-- It wasnt that... okay
Alright
I do look pretty handsome, Mei. I am wearing my best pants for this
Accentuates my bull okay, okay? Well that's not good, but I bet it's better than what you're gonna do
Mei sucks... okay.
Shut the fuck up Mei Oh
Mei sucks you got a zero. I like how this is rigged against you. That's pretty good in my opinion it
Mei sucks... Mei's bad... Okay
All right, you can stop that it's really not that big a deal Mei also
I think your shirts not gonna be able to handle the structural integrity of your bouncing
You haven't done your best
*quietly* You havent done your best?
What did I tell you about doing your best Mei huh? Oh what oh what oh, what oh?
Oh?
What?
Ow, shit what did I hit? Okay, Mei you're going down again
Well you're going down this time cause I'm gonna stand way back here
To start out the next round you ain't never gonna see this watch this shit. Okay. I call this my pimp strut. Oh
Shit Mei you about to get booked
Okay
You look superb I know right I am quite handsome
fuck
Yeah, you should be scared
Little baby gonna cry watch this shit, okay?
I know. I don't know what you said, but I know all right what the fuck have I ever told you that you suck Mei
Okay
You got one. It's not that big a deal Mei. I know you're gonna lose, so I'm just taking a look at your apartment
I'm gonna own this I'm pretty sure we bet oh
How is that a 3??
Alright, Mei, come on. What do you got? What do you got Mei? What do you got? What do- You got nothing!
Not that exciting okay, all right Mei? This date really sucks. Also. I don't know what kind of date
You invite me over to your apartment to play darts? Really bizarre, I mean
I thought we could go out see a movie or something, but this is okay, too. I guess all right last shot
You really got a chance of this. Oh, yeah?
Really good job, Mei. You're doing great. What no no. That's so sad for you
You're standing too close to the darts? No, I'm not you are a liar listen
You're a goddamn liar, and if you if you
if you think
Nice nice hair nice nice. If you think I'm gonna allow you
If you think I'm gonna allow you to call me a cheater
Ain't gonna stand for it, so no we're not gonna play again
Why am I doing this? Because I wanted to win really badly, and I wanted to win at this date
Which I am cause I'm great. Oh God. Why are you oh shit?
Why does she have a gun? I don't- why does she have a gun oh?
Oh, we're already a couple nice vr- oh
No
Kleen who's Kleen?
Okay, this is getting way too meta. I don't even know okay, I
Well, I didn't did I get any vanish?
The game she recommended were horrible. I hope not this time well. That's a little rude
Wow- It's, um... okay. This is getting too meta, I Oh
fire missiles oh
Mei, I'm not too sure about this Mei
It's getting I mean I'm playing a VR game in a VR- do I have to kill you?
All right, well what get ready to get fucked Mei
Missiles away, oh shit alright. Well what the fuck? Hey? Oh my god. I don't understand
What's happening or why Mei? Where did you go?
Mei? Mei? Oh, Oh hi Mei. why do you get so much bullshit, and I get nothing okay, Mei's gone now oh
Shit, that's a little scary Mei. I think it's one of those situations
Where if you die in the game you die in real life?
And I don't want to test that theory. This is a really impressive VR game inside this VR game.
I guess oh hey Mei! Ah get ready to die
And oh, I'm so sorry Mei you suck, I win you suck
I'm the best. I don't really feel good about it, but I feel like I won oh, fucking, hi.
You were ruthless when shooting yes, I was that's how you win listen here, you little shit
I don't care if you're digital or not I-
I...
Don't care, I don't want to do this
I don't want to talk to you like this, but you are giving me a lot of sass. I know that heads
Eugh, I know that heads empty
Hey, why don't these work this VR okay there we go sorry?
Hmm that doesn't seem right
Hmm well that's not normal all right listen make all right listen, Mei. You need to take this seriously
It was a very serious game that you need to take seriously, Mei. If you don't take it seriously you could lose and die
Probably I bet I could do this on hard nobody make any jokes about that. All right Mei. Get ready to get shot
like crazy Oh
Scawy I think that would be instant death, but why does Mei get all the cheaty shit
I don't care if it's supposed to make it more fair. It's bullshit. whoo Mei's tricking me out there, huh?
Nope, Mei you're going down. Mei, I'm just gonna go straight for you. Oh shit.
Hey! Mei! You suck!
I'm the best. I know it don't even try to pretend like you don't know it
You're not reconciled no you lose, and you stay lost this date sucks
All right, I guess. This is all been leading up to this moment
This moment this sweet moment in my life when I'm gonna feel love for better experience. Please take a seat
*Mark laugh*
Guys, I think we - I think we know where this is going
Is what virtual reality has been leading up to all my life
Hang on. I got a angle the camera down for this bad boy here. I'll just sit back and relax
All right sitting properly and ready oh, I am hang on wait hang on. I am ready, and I am sitting
properly
Let's do this
You're stuffed. Not yet. We've barely gotten started. Oh
Uh-oh
I don't want black beans. Well neither do I. I think. You won't eat it. What kind of spoiled shit are you?
Well I don't want your portion
What a spoiled little shit, I don't care how small your shirt is you're gonna eat these black beans
What the fucking....
What? Habit.. what? It's like the rock paper scissors... You gotta use the chop- for beating what
What's the big deal about these black beans? What's wrong with- I'll do scissors. Oh?
Okay, all right
The game is tied indeed it is paper
Oh, No
Buh, oh good fuck you ready to eat some black beans oh shit
This is what my life has been waiting for my whole life
Um...
'Kay...
Nope okay that admittedly that one got away from me good job. Okay? Wait wait wait well, that's
Good fuck you fuck you fuck you and fuck this goddamn dinner
I deserve to give you a black bean that shit. Sorry about your boob I
Can't throw very hard. You saw me playing darts bullshit
Its fucking bullshit. It's bullshit give me your chopsticks
It's fucking bullshit
You're fucked
Why did I lose again?
It's cause you suck, do you want cherry? flower you got um?
You got a you got a plate in your boob you all right?
You need-?
Alright, sorry I just need- Sorry
You're clogged up there I needed to help clear you out a little bit all right there you go
Well that was weird
You are... I?
Hope you are a fully grown adult that is able to make your own decisions and not complain about these black beans that you're eating
Hey wow you suck
Help you with your... I don't...
This is weird...
Say aaa there you go shove it in there, okay wow
I'm really excited about this do we have to play again? Why do we have to do this?
Oh look at that you suck
I don't know why maybe it's programmed to make you lose
Shove it right up your nose, and that's good job. whoa. Oh, wow you do suck
You're really bad at this
That's not right I'm not right about that can I eat it all right? Whatever there you go
They're just actually turds
The black beans are finally finished. Why was that such a concern of yours?
why were you so incredibly worried-  whaa that's
Uh, oh, what're you doing?
Oh hello
Okay, hi
Let's play something different, okay
A forehead flicking game- what the fuck is a forehead flicking?
Can you not flick your fingers on my forehead
Uuuuuh
Wait, what the fuck were you about to hit me? why do I keep having to play rock paper scissors
I don't know. I don't understand what the forehead flick game is hi
Excuse you look I don't lose anything not even
Forehead flick. I hope this laser pointer blinds. Got a chord and ,you know, chords, and oh my god
I got chords in the wedge. Oh my god. I got chords in the way. Please cover your cleavage you yeah you
No, no
Don't please aah aah. Oh my god. I think you bit out a piece of my neck that was unpleasant at best
Okay, I win, please do not no no no no no okay. All right. Well narrowly avoided death again
Yes sure I guess I have to do this nine times. I'm not 100% sure why but I have to go whoop oh
Don't don't please No
Okay, thank you for that
Okay, well I suck please don't no
oh
It goes into my brain blue buff lab a Boop there. We go got ya all right listen listen. Yep
Sorry, hey, Baba hope
Sorry
No, I oh
Okay, sorry yeah
Fucking hell. Just eat your goddamn black beans
Yeah, probably
Chippewa whoo I got you. All right listen don't you think I have a girlfriend you're gonna. Do scissors someday
You're gonna do fucking scissors someday, or you're gonna feel the rock in another place that you don't want
Can you fucking just... please
Do fucking scissors
Can you just do fucking scissors, I don't want
Okay...
Yes, yes yes, ah all right one more now you gonna do
Yes, I want to play again. I don't even know what the reward is for the end of this, but it better be worth it
There you go, you're done, okay?
Nope, don't like that. Thank you
No I do not want to play again. Did I win? What did I win yeah? Yeah, that's right
I don't want to play again. What did I win do I still need to sit down hello? Oh?
I don't know what this is and I don't know if I should still be seated for it Oh
Nope, did you see my letter? I don't know red envelope
For the reunion. I don't know what reunion you're talking about, but you look lovely I guess
huh
Huh.. .wha?
Huh, what are we talking about?
I don't even know if I can. Listen lady. I don't even know if we're dating. Help me find the red envelope
Listen I don't even know if we're dating or what this is gonna get me what reunion are we talking about are we friends?
Are we high school roommates?
this one Oh
God don't mind as I wreck your entire apartment. I've gotta find it. I've gotta find the red envelope
It's got to be in here somewhere. Don't worry Mei. I've got this
Nope not in there nope not in there. Don't worry Mei. I'm gonna find it. Oh it can't escape from me
I'm just a goddamn expert at all this what the fuck is red envelope. Why do you have so many red books? This is bullshit?
You know oh?
Hey, Mei. Guess what I found? A red envelope. You're the best I found it for you. Oh, hey, how's it going?
You have to go oh, no, that's so sad
No wait, whoa whoa whoa whoa? Whoa? Whoa whoa Mei whoa?
Mei you're just...
Mei we barely... I don't want to do that okay...
Oh...
Mei
Mei I
That's you said bye-bye and it said it said see you... oh shit you're leaving me to clean Oh
Bye, bye bye but... no
Mei!
Mei...
Mei, I'm lost without you
Mei, you can't just leave me like this
What about the black beans?
What about the rock, paper, scissors
Mei!
Meeei!
I fell in love... I fell in love and now I'm sad and alone... now I have nobody to my...
To hold me at night...
Mei...
I just...
Mei, I miss you...
Yeah I guess that's it then...
Guess um... yeah
Guess I just...
Guess I just
Say goodbye...
That's it... I guess that's the life lesson you fall in love. You play rock scissors, you force feed your significant other some black beans
And then you watch them run off...
Forever...
If you have love in your heart, you've lost like I've just lost
Let me know what you think in the comments down below
Thank you everybody so much for watching
You wanna see more stuff like this and by stuff like this I mean
Have my heart broken and left on the floor
bleeding, alone
Let me know down in the comments below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I'll see you
In the next video
Buh-Bye!